[Music]
[Applause]
all right fan Corrections this of course
is a segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show now so far hundreds
and hundreds of challengers not one
winner
we don't make mistakes thank God they
keep trying yeah what else would be
doing right now exactly well tonight a
fan named Brian halep off thanks that
who caught a mistake yeah he says he
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when I was talking recently
about the Carnival cruise ship fiasco
hello Conan my name is Brian and I found
an error with your monologue in last
week's Valentine's Day episode use the
idiom so you were making fun of Carnival
Cruise Line and how they once had an
accent in which sixteen ships crash
together to spell out the words we suck
I brought this Carnival cruise ship
disaster he actually had worse things
happen to them and of course the
gigantic crash of sixteen ships spilling
out from the sky the words we suck now
Conan as you can clearly see there are
not sixteen ships there are actually 24
ships in this picture 16 and 24 are not
the same number so therefore you may
compare and by the way Conan in case you
were wondering where I got those awesome
sound effects for clearance reasons I
made them myself
I just want to congratulate him on
whoever does his lighting I think it's
fantastic don't forget to leave room for
my shadow well sorry
Bryan halep off if that's even your real
name what does this do uh anyway you are
dead wrong there were sixteen ships
involved in that crash not 24 don't
believe me
here's the CEO of Carnival Cruise Lines
to back me up
hi Bryan my name is Jerry Cahill I'm the
president and CEO of Carnival Cruise
Lines I'm sorry to say that Conan is
right I will not explain the math to you
and also supply the sound effects here's
a photo of the trash let's start with
the W you thought that was five ships
but it's actually one right it was very
hard to steal because our ship designed
to look like the letter e any better
oh no still that's two ships where you
saw nine let's continue right you're
right about the S
you and the C are each one and a
half and the K is five ships that makes
fifteen ships
where's the sixteenth ship two miles
below the surface in the grip of a giant
squid so there you have it
Kona was right and you Brian were wrong
I'm sorry to say it but you must have
four brains and as president and CEO of
Carnival Cruise Lines I know a thing or
two about
[Applause]
right we thank you so the challenge
still stands you to think you spotted an
error on our show reported at team
koco.com / haha I found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro